my name is little person i'm chairman of
arabian consultants for business
development i'm at the web at the Dead
Sea I have a variety of questions that
have been asked for me many of them have
to do a job creation and the role of
youth Arab entrepreneurs what do they
need to succeed and they need to
understand the strengths of the region
they need to understand the strengths
with it among countries within the
region and I think with the use of
social media with the use of the
internet they can finalize to cooperate
with each other I think the one thing
that needs to create jobs and Jordin we
found that the virtual space has been
very very useful in helping the youth
create jobs and create a lot of
innovation that is not currently
reflected in the physical space which
deals with governmental rules and
regulations dealing with customs
registrations and not sort it is my
belief that when the government business
the government developed business
environment gets as easy to operate as
the virtual space that you will see huge
growth in economic development in
economic activity